could this really be a catalyst in the
gold market if there's a lot of ifs here
so first of all it really depends on how
heavy this is and the patent for this is
actually pretty opaque so is it gold
plated is it actually made of gold I
mean the idea that actually should be
twice as hard as regular gold standard
so it's more resistant to cracks and say
your gold ring so it's a lot of
questions and to that I'll be looking at
how heavy will this actually be so 18
karat gold is about 75% gold I did the
crude math and sort of broke it down on
how much that would cost for about one
gram and turns out it's about a about
$31 based on twelve hundred dollar gold
prices for 18 karat gold so if there are
30 grams in one foam that cost could be
about a thousand dollars if Apple
produces 1 million phones a month that
would be 33 tons of gold so a lot of ifs
here when you're talking about this but
Piper Jaffray gene munster says you know
an average selling price could be
seventy five hundred dollars for Apple
for this phone seventy five hundred
dollars average selling price I'm a
lower-end about a five thousand Wow
alright so what is the worry here is
there enough supply well ok let's break
this down first the real question is is
this Apple phone going to be considered
jewelry or electronics because
electronics demand is actually falling
and jewelry demand is really the
lifeblood of gold it makes up about
fifty four percent of demand technology
demand by the way was it a seven-year
low last year according to the world
gold council so how do you categorize it
on the margin experts are telling me you
know probably not mine production was
about over 33 thousand tons last year if
Apple ships a million phones a month
that's 33 tons a year 393 excuse me 397
tons a year I'm like totally born with
all these numbers basically yeah yes we
totally have enough supply to absorb if
we make about 1 million of these gold
phones however Frank Holmes at us global
investors says it's not about the supply
it's about the perception raw apples
coming out and saying look gold is a
luxury item and we want to be selling it
he says that actually goes a really want
long way in validating gold and China
obviously an enormous market China and
India kind of vie for the biggest demand
driver for gold and China eats up 18
carat gold items eats them up especially
a
your people about 10 million people in
china by gram gold every month that's an
enormous number and Frank home said if
that is the target that could actually
be a mover not necessarily with the
price or with the market but in terms of
actual demand and that goes a long way
in the validating it all right Alex
thank you so might if it's cool i'm 55
grand seven bout five to seven that I
don't know she's I think not sure what
to think about it all right thank you so
much Alex teal